[Music]
now to a story that's been developing
throughout the night an active shooter
in pahrump left a normally quiet street
shaken sasha loftis has been there all
night speaking with nye county sheriff
deputies and also concerned neighbors
the house where the situation ended is
right here behind me neighbors we spoke
with tonight say it was unsettling to
hear and see this all happen in an area
that's normally safe and quiet i heard a
regular i guess they were pistol shots
and then these big boom
gunshots ring out on this normally quiet
street nighttime copy shot fired turning
a thursday in night county terrifying
sorrowful i'm a little worried you know
because it was close to home pamela
stroud lives right around the corner
from what law enforcement called an
active shooter situation it's a horrible
situation for everybody captain david
berukowicz says they were first called
to a home where the suspect's girlfriend
lived they then tracked him down at his
home here off dana way where he
continuously shot at law enforcement and
threatened to kill them obviously none
of us want to be here
but it is what it is and our residents
can know that the sheriff's office takes
their safety seriously deputies later
discovered the man inside and they
believe he shot himself
pamela calls it a sad situation who
knows how many other situations will
come up like that but she's glad it
wasn't worse and hopes to return to her
subdued open space i just wish i could
have been able to help you know
the night county sheriff's office says
the suspect was taken to desert view
hospital earlier tonight no word on his
condition now as for the deputies
involved a few of them were exposed to
chemical irritants used to lure the
suspect out tonight but we're told they
are ok
reporting in perum sacha loftis 8 news
now